in the last couple of minutes we've
heard that harry and megan are expecting
another baby let's speak to our royal
correspondent brianna mills she's on the
phone
um rhiannon baby archie is going to be a
big brother
yeah that's right it was just after 20
past seven
this evening that we had a confirmation
from
harry and megan's spokesperson over in
america
with this happy news perfect news course
valentine's evening
the statement said we can confirm that
archie is going to be
a big brother the duke and duchess of
sussex
are overjoyed to be expecting their
second child and to accompany that news
uh they released a photograph that was
taken by
what's described as their longtime
friend and photographer missan harriman
and you can see in that photograph megan
lying
on the grass with her head in harry's
lap
and you can see a very distinctive baby
bump that she has her hand
uh resting on so yeah wonderful news uh
for the couple
of course it was around this time last
year that we were talking about the fact
that they
were moving away to start this new life
over in america
the fact that they wanted to step away
as uh senior royals the fact that they
were becoming frustrated
about the amount of media attention
around them as a couple
but also around their son archie as well
so archie
is going to be two in may and we know
that they have been fiercely protected
with his privacy
as they've been trying to set up their
new life over in america
so i think obviously to the couple this
is really
lovely news especially after we know
that they experienced the miscarriage
uh last summer megan very movingly wrote
about that experience and how difficult
it was
for both her and harry to go through
that experience
um so yeah some really lovely news that
they are now expecting
uh another child um their second child
and i think for the couple this of
course
obviously is being announced in a very
different way from how we would usually
expect with members of the royal family
they've decided to step away
uh senior royals so in some ways they've
it's allowed them to probably delay that
news
delayed the the announcement in some way
um but yeah clearly they've decided that
now is the moment that they want to tell
the world